anne warshaw une multitude de teintes le
bitume et le moyen d'expression de
daniel convenant après avoir découvert
ce matériau en 2008 l'artiste peintre en
a fait sa marque de fabrique
ça représente le temps le diable c'est
le budget du tout le pétrole que
lui-même ne garder la composition des
matériaux comme le bois et tout ça est
donc pour moi c'est ça représente le
temps je parle par des périodes plus en
plus ou moins long de réfection et tout
ça jusqu'au jour où j'ai eu l'idée est
donc le premier geste c'est évident d'un
seul coup et pour moi c'est l'élégance
au coeur de ses créations la figure de
l'arbre son écorce et ses noeuds par ses
tableaux daniel convenant cherche à
exprimer ses émotions sur le temps la
vie et la mémoire
un art intimement lié son avc en 1993
qui l'a plongé dans le coma pour moi
larmes c'était ma la confection donc je
suis rentré dans le tronc de l'arbre
pourquoi le trompe
tout simplement parce que c'est c'est
entre l'ombre à l'une est la racine et
le feuillage d'haleine la lumière donc
c'était le trait d'union entre les deux
tout ce je le fais à chaque fois c'est
une toile
c'est une partie de moi même c'est un
instant devant de mari donc c'est
impensable c'est la quantité de lait de
butô c'est comme le bitume
c'est ma route daniel convenant revient
à guyancourt après y avoir exposé il ya
19 ans ses oeuvres sont à découvrir
jusqu'au 28 janvier en août
elles partiront pour le centre national
des arts de tokyo